- It's a hell of a lot
better to try to become liked
because you're helping another human
than because you bought Gucci loafers.
(upbeat jazzy music)
Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuck.
This is it!
This is episode 300 of the
Ask Gary Vee Show, Scott,
and I'm very excited.
I made a big to do and told them,
we gotta save this slot.
It's gotta be this big thing.
- 300.
Didn't the make that movie about that?
- Exactly, the warrior.
- This is-
- [Woman] Ask Garry Vee Show!
(screams)
- I think this is super special.
A, you've been on the show before,
and B, I think what better slot to use
than for somebody I admire,
who's on a project that I admire,
and so for the Vayner
nation who's watching,
why don't you tell them who you are
and what you're doing
here on this special day?
- I'm happy to come up to you this time.
- [Garry] Thank you.
- So 12 years ago started an organization
called Charity: Water.
Very simple mission.
Bring clean drinking water-
- And your name, and your name, tell them.
- Oh yeah, sorry, Scott Harrison.
- Yeah, I wanna help
get every single person
on Earth clean drinking water,
and been at that now for 12 years.
I love what you've been saying lately
about showing up for not a year
or nine months or nine weeks,
it's really been 12 years
of really really hard work.
That's the mission, to
get everybody clean water,
then the vision is really
to reinvent charity.
And you and I have talked
about this over the years.
So many people don't trust charity,
so many people aren't giving.
There's a cynicism, there's a skepticism.
And we just tried to
design the perfect charity.
What would people want to give to?
What would it feel like?
How would we handle their money?
What would those feedback loops look like?
So it's been 12 years
of trying to innovate
in that direction as well.
- And I'm hopeful that
this has hit your radar
because I probably bring
it up once a month,
or even if you're not cynical,
or you don't think about giving,
and you come from a good place.
You were brought up the way I was,
which is in a society that you
worked hard your whole life,
and then you got older,
and then you started giving away money.
That was just my framework.
When you, me, and Chris Sacca were
in the basement of that bar
in the meat packing district,
I always say this because
I think I do this a lot
for my employees and other people,
sometimes one sentence just
clicks in the right way,
you looked me dead in the
face and you were like
you're a good dude,
you did your intuition thing,
I think you're good dude
and you're just gonna
do the cliche thing.
Why not give now?
And I'm like, why not give now?
Like no different than all those
clips I've put on Instagram
where I'm like or you could quit your job,
and then the person's
like, I can quit my job.
And then everybody in the comments,
he's fucking speaking common sense.
He doesn't say anything that profound.
What the fuck?
You didn't say anything so crazy.
You just said to me, "Or
you could start giving now."
- And I thought it would be fun.
Why would you deprive yourself of the fun
of being able to use
your time and your talent
and your money to get involved
with a bunch of great causes
and see that impact now?
See organizations grow.
I mean we've been working for 10 years.
At the very beginning we
were Big Omaha, right?
There was no Charity: Water.
It was an idea.
We might have gotten
a few hundred thousand
people clean water,
and we've now been friends 10 years
and that number is about
to be 10 million people
with clean water at the end of this year.
And you know I know Pencils,
like you've seen the impact
of both time and money.
- And you know it evolves,
I apologize for interrupting.
I think one of the things
for everybody watching,
somebody asked me this the other day,
and I've never really said this public,
I'm gonna use it as this framework
because I am kind of quiet
about the good things I do.
It's interesting.
Obviously I'm on the board
of Pencils of Promise.
Obviously Charity: Water well member.
Obviously I spent a lot of time
on the Crones and Colitis
Foundation because of AJ.
Done a good amount with autism
and things of that nature
because of Matt Higgins, my partner,
but it's been interesting.
The evolution is fascinating.
One of the things that's
really evolved with me
in 2018 and 17,
is giving to people I kind of know.
So one of the things
that's really struck me,
much like I think about microinfluencers
and volume content that scale,
one of the things in my giving
life that has hit me more
is these gives when it's,
you know one thing that everybody says,
getting older one of
the real not fun things
is things start happening.
And just people that I've shared,
I'm just thinking about
something right now,
somebody hit me up,
just cold DM on Twitter.
Luckily I was just scrolling through,
which I don't check as much
as on I do on Instagram.
And she's like look, I know this woman.
I've seen her seven or
10 times in business.
Keynote speeches, things of that nature.
And she's like I'm sick and
I've got this Go Fund Me,
and like it wasn't even a hesitation.
And it felt great.
Because the context is there.
It's not as much as giving to a big or,
which big mission,
I mean your mission is so
the most fun.
By the way,
I talk a lot these days about perspective.
Boy has being involved helped me,
and use real life analogies
of like yes, I understand
you're very upset
that your stock went down today.
Let me tell you about people
that walk seven hours to get clean,
and you know what's great about water?
There's always water.
I'm always like you know how
you're devastated right now,
you know that bottle?
- You're always pointing to it.
- [Gary] I'm always pointing to it.
- It's in the frame.
- You know that right there?
You have that.
You could go to the sink right now.
There are literally people who walk five,
six, seven, eight hours
through dangerous situations
whether it's animals or
fucking just getting hurt
or getting robbed.
It's just people lack perspective.
- Two things that I was thinking of.
One I really believe people
give to people, not causes.
Most people give to people.
So even if you look at
our fundraising movement.
It's like the nine year old kids
donating their birthday.
The 35 years olds walking
across the country.
- Or how you built it.
The original pillars
of this, I gave to you.
And through you to them.
- Yeah and someone said to me once.
He said, "Look, I get to
support all these causes."
He said, "Scott, I get to
live vicariously through you.
"I can't go to 69 countries like you.
"I can't go to Ethiopia 30 times,
"but I feel like I'm living
vicariously through your work,
"like you're the conduit
for me to this issue."
And this person was supporting
a bunch of other causes.
He starts listing.
He's like "This is a great joy to me,
"that I'm a part of this
work around the world.
"Work here domestically,
work internationally,
"and I'm able to do that with my money."
the other thing I was just thinking of
because it seems like you've really
found the joy of giving these days.
I believe the more you
give the more you give.
You get almost addicted to the generosity.
- Well I'll be honest with you.
The thing that clearly is more,
and this is probably my
biggest delta with you,
and I've been able to get
into the field with POP
way more than I have with Charity: Water
for many different reasons,
but to me giving money,
one of the things that
I want to do more of,
specifically with Charity: Water,
and this is kind of like
I've done a good job
on using my platform to
continue to bring you exposure.
And that makes me feel good.
- And we hear about it, yeah.
People discover us through you.
- But I wanna do more.
The thing that I'm most addicted to
is getting feedback loop of people
that right now I'm completely
and utterly addicted
to the fact that I started
pushing garage sale culture.
And we talked about it before we went on.
Look, there's no high bigger
for me than the thousands,
we're now into the tens
of thousands of comments
that I'm getting in DM,
you see the public ones.
If you follow me heavy the retweets
of people's Ebay accounts
that I love doing almost every day.
- That's how I got started though.
I mean you remember I
sold 2,000 DVDs on Ebay.
- [Gary] I was very
aware, your whole stack.
- To pay for the Mercy.
Then I went out to yard sales.
I was telling these guys,
I found electro sonic mics.
I was putting up every
single thing I could
to fund the two years on the Mercy Ships.
And then just liquidated my life.
- Stop because for everybody watching,
we're gonna link up the prior episode.
Oh, if you wanna ask Scott a question,
for knowing my audience,
A, please ask about
nonprofits, Charity: Water,
but listen let's call it what it is.
- It doesn't need to be nonprofit stuff.
- And that's right.
And I think where I really
wanna go is like look,
we're not gonna go into it.
You can watch a prior episode which we did
of Ask Gary Vee at Charity: Water
and we'll link that here,
we'll figure out what
episode number that was
where you can get a lot
of the origin story.
- I don't think you swore
once in that entire episode.
- [Gary] Is that true?
- It was amazing.
- Whoa.
- I had this effect on you.
- You always have a good effect on me.
- Speaking of which though, swearing,
good effects, bad effects,
like all those things.
Look, Scott was a wildly
successful club promoter,
all the vices that would
get everybody excited about,
he always puts in his spiel.
I always love his first three minutes.
I mainly like watching other young people,
watch their faces,
I've heard it so many times
that the last 20 times I've
been in a room with Scott
- You're just watching;
you're looking back.
- I'm watching everybody else
because he's talking
about models and champagne
and exotic stuff and I'm
watching all the faces,
and it just so funny, like
the cliche 20 year old
is like well that sounds pretty good.
You are an unbelievable
marketing and brand mind.
That's the truth.
One of the biggest
reasons that I gravitated
towards your organization,
besides the transparency
and the dollars going to,
one of the reasons I did the well,
which is a real substantial commitment
was because it allowed you to make
every one of these, everybody's
who's watching right now,
if they go to Charity: Water,
and they donate five
dollars or their birthday
because it's the 26th birthday,
they can give $26,
the fact that me and how many individuals
are now in the well?
- 131 families.
- Those 131 families, very
special families by the way,
for many different reasons, who they are.
But who they are, not who they are.
I don't know what the
math works out these days,
but that being able to
subsidize the overhead
of the organization.
- So let me talk about them.
I mean there's two bank accounts.
For people that don't
know the organization.
Two years, when we basically said-
- I apologize I wanna get this.
If you have a question,
marketer, networker, brander,
I wanna talk about the book,
that's why we're here right?
- Yeah, and I'm so excited,
people are gonna actually call in.
- [Gary] You didn't bring the book?
- I sent you one today,
I messengered it out.
We got it somewhere.
- Tyler, can we find the book?
- I'm pretty proud of it.
It looks good.
There's pictures.
- There was a book
messaged here, you got it?
He's gonna figure it out.
There's a new book out.
When did it come out, a couple weeks ago?
- [Scott] Four weeks.
- Four weeks.
Saw it was doing really well,
which makes me excited.
- [Scott] Made the Times list.
- A, I want everybody to pick up the book.
We'll try to find it and put it up here,
but we'll superimpose it if not.
But if you have a question for Scott,
please email garyveeteam@vaynermedia.com.
Garyveeteam@vaynermedia.com.
Ask your question in the headline.
Put your phone number in the body.
Garyveeteam@vaynermedia.com.
We'll get to some of those question.
So go ahead, two bank accounts.
- I was just saying,
131 people pay for all the overhead,
the AD staff, the offices,
the flights, all that stuff.
And then over a million donors
have gotten this pure play,
where 100% of their five bucks or $500,000
goes directly out to the projects.
So your and Lizzy's support has been
so valuable in that way.
And look, this is why
people aren't giving.
And there's a lot of really
smart people out there.
There's a guy called Dan Pallotta,
gave a famous TED Talk
raging against this idea
that big overheads are bad.
We're like, we believe Dan,
but that's an uphill battle.
We're just gonna create a
different business model.
We're gonna go find 131 people,
the founders of Facebook
and Twitter and Spotify
and Wordpress.
You've got 50 friends in that program.
And say hey help us pay
for the software engineers.
Help us pay for the phone bills
and the Epson copy machine.
So that we can go out
to millions of people
and say every single bit
of your donation will go.
And then we'll track it.
And the last time we talked,
we were just starting to
put sensors in our wells.
We now have 3,500 wells online.
We have another 2,000 about to go online.
And we're monitoring
over a billion liters.
Look it's here!
Wow, two of them!
Tyler, one's for you.
- Tyler, one for you, brother.
- Alright, this is it.
- This is it!
- This was two years to
write, some pictures in it.
- Let's put it up, let's
make sure they can see it.
Look, I think one of the
things that happened-
- All the money goes.
I gave away the advance.
I know you told me not to, but-
(laughs)
- I think that what's really
powerful about this story
is when you market in a contemporary way,
so much of the content,
which you guys have been
continued building better
and better skills around,
builds so much awareness,
so much of under 35
has gravitated to an
organization like this,
and again, even look at
the faces in this room.
If they get inspired, which many have,
time and time and again.
And by the way, but ups to Instagram Live,
who's watching now.
We're on the Ask Gary
Vee Show episode 300.
Scott Harrison, the
founder of Charity: Water.
New book, I want you to pick it up,
but more importantly,
Instagram if you're watching,
if you have a question for
Scott as you keep listening,
Thank you.
Garyveeteam@vaynermedia.com.
Ask your question in the headline.
Your phone number in the body.
Garyveeteam@vaynermedia.com.
Put your question in the headline.
Phone number in the body.
A lot of the people that
are watching now skew young,
knowing my audience.
When you give $20,
and so by the way, I know on the site,
you can give the birthday thing was huge.
- So the birthday worked.
That did about 60 million bucks.
- That idea created $60,000,000?
- That and then some people donating
running across mountains.
- Seth, how old are you?
- Or fundraising campaigns,
$65,000,000 I think.
- What's that?
When do you turn 29?
Great.
- You're too long.
- What's that?
- Right, fair enough.
Who's close birthday, like me?
By the way, my birthday
is literally Wednesday.
When I turn 43, I'm gonna
try to sell some wine
because I'm gonna be selfish, I'm 43.
But on my 44th birthday,
what I wanna give up.
- $44 for your 44th.
- And what you do is you create a page,
you ask all your friends and
acquaintances and relatives
to just donate $44 to Charity: Water,
and that's the gift.
And if you think about it,
it works so many ways over.
Number one, like a guy like me,
my family's been yelling all week,
what do we get you?
I'm like don't get me anything.
- Give me a tax deductible
receipt to Charity: Water.
- [Gary] Is that what it is?
- Give people clean water.
No!
Someone can get handbags,
wallets, ties, gift cards,
or give people clean water.
The idea was just to create this movement
of generosity around birthdays.
We don't really need more stuff,
and people don't even have clean water.
660,000,000 people don't have clean water.
- One more time, throw
that number out there.
- A tenth of the planet.
One out of every 10 people
right now is drinking bad water.
So 663,000,000 people.
- And how many of those
people live in Africa?
- About a third.
About a third in India, a
third in southeast Asia.
- That's really where it's at.
- A little bit in Central
and South America,
but I'd say some of the biggest hardship-
- Just because I'm watching the faces
in this room, which means the
faces behind the computers.
Talk to me about bad water.
So brown, diseases in it.
Help everybody understand bad.
- I wish we could almost
cut in the images.
It's disgusting.
It's brown, viscous.
It's this.
I don't know if you guys
can find this image.
- [Gary] We can zoom in, yeah.
- I photographed this little girl-
- [Gary] Right there, there's a camera.
- In Kenya, drinking this water,
and she would vomit on herself
every time she drank from this bottle.
So it was this terrible cycle of disease.
And 52% of all the disease
throughout the developing world
is caused by that water.
So half the sick people
don't need to be sick,
they just had clean water and toilets.
And the women are walking, like you said,
six hours a day often.
40 billion hours are wasted just by women
every year in Africa getting water.
So it's this huge problem
that impacts women.
It impacts girls.
The girls are dropping out of school.
- Just let's play here a little.
When you started this,
let me go a different way.
In 2011, 12, 13, 14, 15,
when I was involved
watching it gain momentum,
the atmosphere in America was different.
With the political climate,
with the cultural climate,
have you found it more
difficult in the last 12 months
to get people to care about this issue
when a lot of people have
started really caring
about domestic issues, race, gender,
like the fires in California.
Just watching our circle
on Instagram this weekend,
I would say 50% of the people that I saw
talking about and
donating and doing stuff.
- And we're giving to that.
We're doing that stuff.
- [Gary] Listen, I know you are.
- I mean, you and I, personally,
not the organization.
- Yes, we are, yes.
But have you found over
the last 18 months,
more of a challenge for
people to get excited
about a girl in Kenya
during the current state
of vibes in America.
I'm just curious for my own learning.
- So the numbers would say no.
So we drew 40% last year.
- I know but you're on
the pulse, thoughts?
Because what's your gut telling you?
- I actually think it's getting easier.
- Talk.
Fascinated.
Not expected, go.
- So in perhaps the most
toxic political environment
certainly of my lifetime,
where people are angry,
people hate each other,
this is something that people can
actually agree to agree on.
- Interesting.
- So I've got right wing Republicans,
I've got left wing Democrats,
I've got Jews and Christians and Muslims
and Atheists and Mormons.
Like Mormons are running
$100,000 campaigns.
Synagogues are sending in money.
Muslim school kids
during Ramadan in Dubai.
It's this thing that people can say
if we don't have clean
water, what have we got.
And we can agree to agree on that.
So we've seen growth in this toxic period.
And I think as well that there is a sense
of Americans want to be
seen as good neighbors.
We wanna outstretch our arms
across an ocean and end
the suffering of others
and say we do care about you.
We see you little girl.
We see the conditions you were born into,
and we can do something about it.
I think we also have now
12 years of building trust.
We've raised $330,000,000.
So we've got a third of
a billion dollars now
through grass roots,
through the grass roots.
So we now have GPS
coordinates on the wells.
We have sensors on the wells.
We've stuck around.
I know that you're talking about this.
We've stuck around long enough
that it's like oh Charity:
Water I just heard about it.
We've been at it for over a decade.
- Scott I talk about this a lot,
I'll tell you why.
When you are charismatic,
like you are,
and listen because this
is almost me doing it
for my own self,
the amount of times that
people have had conversations
and dinners with me where they're like,
yeah but what's he gonna do next?
Especially when you were so out in front.
It's the same thing with me.
Because I talk about my dream and ambition
to buy the New York Jets,
people struggle with realizing
how good of a guy I am
because I think they can co-exist.
But because you talked about being
an A player in the New York City scene,
and you're so young,
I feel like a lot of
people are just waiting
for you to move on and do something else.
- Well they're waiting a long time.
- [Gary] Well that's exactly right.
- Here's the way I look at it.
So the most common way that
argument's presented to me
is why don't you go out, start a company,
make a ton of money, take
it public, or flip it.
- And then give all the money away.
- As if I'm so talented, okay?
First of all that's a big assumption,
and then give the money away.
And I normally say to them,
how many people do you know
that have given a third
of a billion dollars away?
Okay, and then next year,
that's gonna be $450,000,000.
And then it's 560, and then it's 670,
and then there's gonna be
a billion dollar number
that has flowed through my hands.
I would have to be such an
extraordinary entrepreneur
to go make that much money
that I'm then giving a billion,
and look Gates has done it
and Buffett has done it,
but there's few names.
- Nine, 17,
34 people have done it.
Yeah, we appreciate it.
- But I might be able to
look back at some point
and actually have billions,
if I stay the course,
if I continue to work
hard, build this team,
invite people into the movement,
give nine year old girls a voice
with their lemonade stands.
You understand, we have kids.
There are kids out there.
There are four year olds that are painting
for Charity: Water.
There's a four year old named Cosette
that sold $5,100 of paintings.
There's a nine year old in Vancouver
that did 12 lemonade stands.
One of them was in the rain.
Her mom's like you're not
selling lemonade in the rain.
She was like no I am.
I'm staying out here.
Her last lemonade stand
she convinced a local band
to perform next to the lemonade stand,
and she sells $5,800 in lemonade.
So we wanna be that organization
that A is a little bit of a bomb,
maybe to the toxicity
of we hate each other.
We disagree on everything else.
No, let's come together around generosity.
Let's care for others.
Let's end suffering through a basic need.
Water's like, it's not political.
If I was building schools,
undoubtedly there are
people out there saying,
"What are they learning?
"What ideology are they learning?
"Are the teachers any good?"
Water is a binary good.
It's clean and it's flowing or it's not.
And I think we've just tried
to call people into that,
and now we have over a million people,
and hopefully it's two
million and three million.
- That's amazing.
Now proceeds to the book,
how does that roll out?
- All of it goes to the organization.
I'm not making a penny.
So I turned over the advance.
Every penny going forward.
I wanted it to be pure.
We talked about this.
I don't feel like I could
use the organization
to promote something for personal gain.
It was supposed to be in
the kids' college fund.
That was gonna be the initial idea,
but I want it to go far and wide
and I want it to help a lot of people.
I want it to inspire social entrepreneurs.
There are probably people listening
that have some issue that is not okay
on their watch.
- Who's this?
- Heath, okay.
- [Heath] Hello this is Heath.
- Heath, it's Gary Vaynerchuck.
You're on the Ask Gary Vee
Show with Scott Harrison.
- What's up Heath?
- [Heath] Oh you gotta be kidding me.
- You made it Heath.
- [Heath] That's awesome.
- You made it brother,
what's your question?
- [Heath] First of all, thanks for Scott
for his talk in Pheonix
what was it, yesterday?
Man you're a man on the move.
So thanks for that the
audience was awfully inspired.
- Thanks man, yeah it was yesterday.
- By the way that is one of the great,
we have a lot of connections.
Hunterdon County, New Jersey.
Just a lot of way we see the world,
but no question like living in the airport
is also an equal
connection for Scott and I,
so I just got competitive
he was hustling so hard.
I can't wait to go to
Dubai on Sunday night.
- I've been on about 70 flights this year.
- Go ahead Heath.
- [Heath] So super inspired by the story,
and the innovation that Scott has brought
to the charity space.
I left the corporate world
at the end of the last year.
Have been putting in the ground work
to start up a charity myself.
Kind of mid-40s typical evolution.
I know Scott doesn't
like the words give back.
- Just give, just give.
You wanna give.
- [Heath] I wanna give.
So the question is, we
are the instancy stages
of starting up a charity
for at risk youth,
using Brazilian jiu jitsu, the
sport of Brazilian jiu jisu
as a vehicle to keep them out of gangs,
away from drugs, that sort of thing.
I like a lot of the
innovation that I've seen.
Your model, in terms
of like the 100% model,
storytelling as a foundation
for engaging donors
and things like that.
So obviously you've
set the bar pretty high
in terms of things to implement,
but what I'm interested in
is given my shoes right now
of saying what are the
highest priority things
that we should focus on,
and there's a team of about three or four
of us right now starting this up.
What are the things that we
should initially focus on
to hopefully scale this thing
over the next three to five years?
- Sure.
So two things come to mind.
Get your business model around money down.
I don't think you need
to adopt the 100% model.
It's incredibly difficult.
Hopefully I said this from stage.
I'm trying to tell people.
Running effectively two
organizations in perfect balance
at the same time is
incredibly challenging.
We're lucky to have Gary and
Lizzy and these other families,
but I don't think you need the
100% model to be successful.
What I think you need
is just to tell people
where their money goes.
We're open to a ton of value propositions.
We want clarity around
where the dollars went.
If you told us right now
that your greatest need
was a lawyer to incorporate,
there are people that are saying great,
I'll help you pay those legal fees.
And I think the storytelling,
you've gotta be out of
the gate telling stories
of these youth,
of why your solution is effective.
Give me stories where it's worked.
Show me success stories.
- Scott, there was that viral video.
Kony like the dict right?
- Yeah, the Invisible Children guys, yeah.
- I mean that has a lot of
other things that were going on.
I don't know all the story so
I'm gonna leave it at that.
But they did make, much
like the Dollar Shave Club,
you and I have made a lot-
- We did too, we've got
12 or 13 million views
for the spring now.
And I hired the Kony guys to do it.
- You and I have a lot of videos
that have gone viral.
Then there's that video
and the Dollar Shave Club,
which went to a different level.
When you start getting
into tens and hundreds.
- They got a hundred
like in the first week.
- There's just a big
difference between 100,000,000
in one week on a video.
It's just like me and my personal,
Simon Sinek, our friend,
he's got a couple of videos.
- His millennial talk, right?
- Where I'm going with that brother,
is storytelling isn't,
and what's amazing about the internet,
is that you actually
could be like Scott and I
and just put out a lot of great stuff
which in the collective
eventually creates something,
or you could be like Dollar Shave Club,
literally one video.
Listen, people try to make a viral video
every day of the week.
Today 9,000 people posted on YouTube
something that cost $400,000 to make
with the hope that 100,000,000
people would watch it,
but the stories matter so much.
I'll say one other thing.
The reason Scott has 150 or so families
that are writing substantial checks
to under write the organization
is he leaned into self
awareness at a personal scale.
He's as you know, as
everybody's who's watching,
as you saw on stage, as
my little five person crew
that's sitting here, and as I knew.
When you have that level of
charisma and authenticity
and a way to communicate
that touches somebody,
you have a chance of being able
to create that kind of model.
When I hear somebody say I'm cliche,
and I'm 40 and things have gone
well, and I wanna give back.
I also say to myself, huh,
he also knows four to
seven to 39 other people
that he came up with that also did well
within the industry on his team,
so I always tell people,
lean into self awareness and strengths.
If you're at a position in your mid-40s
where you can afford
to make this transition
and just hearing the way
you delivered the sentence,
I'm like, let's keep it basic here.
Oh shit, he knows other
rich people, right?
And if you make something called the Ring
or the Squared Circle
or the fucking Octagon
or whatever the fuck you wanna call it,
and there's eight people in the Octagon
that launch this charity with you
and they all writing $250,000
check because they can.
Well guess what?
So people shy away from
their strengths sometimes.
I wouldn't.
Does that make sense Heath?
- [Heath] Yeah, point well taken.
And, Gary, I think this question,
the final question that I have,
I think you might be able to lend
some expertise here as well.
One of the big light bulb moments
when I was studying Scott's youth case
was this transition from
traditional charity,
basically starting over at zero every year
in terms of their fundraising
and saying this is a thing
that almost made him quit,
because it's like this
never ending vicious cycle
of we have a great year,
and I can't trump that.
So transitioning to a
recurring revenue model.
Big light bulb went on.
One thing that I've been
chewing around in my brain,
is if we take that approach,
what kind of content can we give back
so that when my credit card expires
and I need to go renew that thing...
- It's the right question
- It's the right question.
- He'll find the answer.
- First of all the fact that you're even,
if you notice how we both reacted,
the question already gives us confidence.
Let me throw one other thing at you.
Yes, content.
I will tell you right now, access.
The biggest thing that I
think people don't understand
is how important access is as well.
So for example, a lot of
what I've been thinking about
is what if January fifth was the day?
What if there was a special day?
What can you do around that day
when everybody reoccurs for the year?
I've been thinking a
lot about Black Friday.
Like it's this heavy commerce day.
Could it become this huge giving day?
And then what do you do around that week?
I think access.
I think one thing that Charity: Water
does extremely well,
and one thing that I'm actually
gonna talk to Scott about
off camera, and now I'm just
gonna share it on camera,
is I think of the big
Charity: Water ball, event
at the end of the year.
And we've talked about,
we never actually, I'd
like to rebring it up,
like a smaller wine version.
I look at it like TED.
TED had this incredibly
big event in Vancouver
and it was such a big deal,
and some people argue
it diluted the brand,
which I would argue is true,
but I think in other ways
it expanded the brand.
They started creating TEDx.
So to me just even hearing
what you're saying,
one of the things you could do
is have like four major
UFC events each year
that certain people get access to
to go with you,
and that Saturday and that
Sunday morning is the brunch.
- Or to go with the kids.
Go to the kids in the program.
- Access.
Like I'll give you one.
If I started something like this tomorrow,
the first thing I would
do is do a live call
in show every Friday
night from 4:00 to 6:00
because I'm good at it,
and more importantly it's access.
So I think access is something
that people gravitate towards too,
not just content,
and as content continues to grow,
it get commoditized, but access doesn't.
The trips to the field.
- Community, that's the second piece.
So Heath, with our
recurring giving program.
We pivoted from the birthdays
at year 10 over to the spring,
which is now, it's been growing,
it's up I think 277%.
It's crazy growth, 104 countries.
- By the way, let me just stop everybody.
I love when people think
things happen by accident.
Nobody talks in terms like 270s,
I think this is important.
- I have the portfolio dashboard.
- Scott, listen, I want
people to understand
what it takes to be successful.
You don't say I think 277%.
You didn't say 300, you didn't say 250.
When you're in your shit,
and you know it's 277.
- I've got it on my phone.
- Great.
So created infrastructure to
have a dashboard on your phone.
It means you're in it.
It means you're thoughtful.
You know how you build
these things brother,
back to like you know why he didn't quit?
You know why Vayner Media doesn't scare me
even though every scope
ends every year too,
it's when you're in your craft.
It's when you're
passionate about something,
you're figuring it out.
You're in the trenches.
- He's got the right questions.
We think you're gonna be successful.
- We do because of the
data of he already was
to get him into this position,
but I wanna say this.
This is me on a tangent.
This is why passive income
scares the shit out of me.
All these kids get tricked
into recurring revenue,
and they think they're
gonna create a landing page,
and they're gonna make money.
And people are gonna
just keep paying them.
And they go to sleep.
There is no recurring revenue.
You gotta be on top of your shit.
- [Heath] And for me it's not in lieu
of doing other fundraising efforts,
traditional fundraising efforts,
I think Scott used a good term,
which he said it just evens
out the peaks and valleys
so that they can better
plan how they're gonna scale
over a three year time frame,
as opposed to being reactive.
Because for me the recurring revenue
is one component, not all.
- Heath, our recurring
is only about right now
about $11,000,000 out of 70.
But the beautiful thing is when you have
that many people giving monthly.
So we've got about 33,000 givers
giving $30 a month on
average from 140 countries
that the halo effect on the
whole organization is huge.
So you can't help but grow
the other parts of it.
I'll give you an example.
There was a woman in Chicago
that was giving 30 bucks a month,
I don't know for five or six months.
She calls up the office,
she gives $50,000,
builds five wells.
She got to know the
organization through that.
Through the content,
through the community.
We just hosted an event in Atlanta
where we just invited
300 of our spring members
just to come and meet each other,
and to meet some of the people
in our water programs team.
Just building community.
So we threw a party for
people giving $30 a month.
So I think you'll figure that out.
The content, the community,
connecting people,
and I think it's gotta
be an important part
of your organization.
So I'm glad you're doing
it from the beginning.
I wish I had done that from the beginning.
I felt like I was 10
years too late on that.
- That's what happens when you innovate.
Good luck brother.
- [Heath] I'm very appreciative
of the model you've built
because it's an easy reflection point
to try to mimic some of the
good things you've put in stuff.
Appreciate that.
- Thank you brother.
- Good luck man.
- Take care, good luck.
- [Heath] Thank you.
- I think it's right.
I think Heath made a
really important point,
and again trying to make this
valuable for my audience,
I always talk about watch
what I do not what I say.
When you watch something,
if you deploy multiple layers.
If you watch what I do, not what I say,
if you deploy self awareness
and know who you are,
you can look at a model,
and then you can decide what you can
and can't do in that model,
and then you can start hacking.
A lot of people can't be on
planes 70-100 days a year.
It's just not in their energy levels,
things of that nature.
But when you can see a framework,
you can start chipping away
and making it your own.
By the way, that's what you did
because you have so many tech friends,
and so many tech founders,
even recurring revenue streams
gets into your lexicon.
- Yeah, and I was talking to people,
I was talking to Daniel Ek at Spotify
about recurring revenue
because he was helping
to pay for the overhead
for six years.
So I think that was
the community of people
that we put ourselves in.
Charity: Water was not hanging
out with other nonprofits.
We were a reading Fast
Company, we were reading Wired.
We were hanging out with
people who were innovating
and trying to learn from
them and ask those questions.
- When did you understand
that that was the next class?
I feel like you dug very deep
into our world very fast.
What made that happen?
- Well it started with Michael Birch.
It started with that
transformative million dollar gift,
what, 11 years ago.
- After they sold Bebo, right?
- After he sold Bebo,
and it's funny I just had
a dinner in San Fransisco
this week and Marissa Meyer
was telling this story
about meeting me 11 years ago.
Someone had set her up,
she comes into Charity: Water
early like crappy office.
- Pheonix?
- [Felix] Hello?
- Well I'll pause the story.
- Hey Pheonix.
Oh Felix!
- [Felix] Felix!
- Felix it's Gary Vaynerchuck,
you're on the Ask Gary Vee Show.
Can you do me one favor?
I'm gonna let Scott finish
this Marissa Meyer story,
and then we're gonna ask your question.
- You asked how I got into it,
so it was Michael Birch.
She gets introduced to
me, walks in the office.
I'm doing my thing on the laptop.
And clicking through all the photos.
I had just come back from Liberia.
She sponsors a couple
water projects and says,
"Hey, you need to be at
TED, I'll sponsor you."
So she sponsors me at TED,
this is back in Monterey, California,
I go.
Someone at the bar that night said,
"Hey, there's this guy named
Chris Sacca that's there.
"He's really important for you I believe.
"If you can get him to
care about your thing,
"that'll open up a lot
of great connections."
He was at Google then.
So I had the PSA that we'd made
with Jennifer Connelly and her kids,
directed by Hotel Rwanda's Terry George.
I had it on an iPod Touch.
Walk up to Sacca, tap him on the back,
and ask him to put headphones
on at the bar at TED
and watch my PSA.
And I think he just did.
So he watches this thing for 60 seconds.
Next thing I know, he's
trying to get TED to play it,
makes the introduction to YouTube.
Next thing we know, we have
the homepage of YouTube
back then to debut the PSA.
Tens of millions of views.
We leveraged that to get
a million dollar spot
on American Idol to run the 60 second PSA.
This all happened from clicking a laptop
with the right person to the
next place to the next place.
I mean I can draw the web of connections.
And you know, Sacca's been
to the field twice now.
- It's how we met.
- [Scott] It's how we met.
- We met at Sacca and
I were testing some...
- So that's what I'm
seeing here is through
you keep rewinding that.
- I believe in that shit the most.
Felix.
- [Felix] Hello.
- You're on the Ask Gary Vee Show
with Scott Harrison.
- Hey Felix.
- [Felix] My heart is about
to jump out of my chest.
I'm trying not to die right now.
- No worries brother,
what's your question?
- [Felix] So my question
is, I put in the email,
how do you find your purpose
without getting sucked into fake ideology?
And I thought it was very
interesting having Scott.
You know, Scott, I had the
pleasure of kind of learning
about you on the Tom
Bilyeu show, Impact Theory,
which Gary just had on his show
which is all very interesting.
That kind of led us to this point.
I had no expectations
for you Gary to call me.
But that is the question
I'd love some help on that.
- Say more about ideology.
Unless you know what he means.
- I have sense but I'm
gonna let him finish.
- [Felix] Some quick context
is to do a little audit of myself.
Flat out just gonna say,
I don't think I'm an entrepreneur,
I don't think I have that in me.
I'm working for a software
company right now.
But I have looked to expand my horizons,
pick up new skills.
I'm trying to teach myself photography,
teach myself videography.
And with really the intent of knowing
that some day that I want
to hopefully impact somebody
in a way where they feel
better about themselves.
I'm on my own journey
where I'm figuring out myself.
Trying to gain perspective on my life.
Figure out what it is that makes me happy,
what it is that makes me motivated.
And going through this process,
I have been self auditing
myself quite a while,
and one thing that I know
I've come to realize,
is that I am crippled really by the idea
of other people's opinion of me.
And I've grown up through my life
with that crippling fact about myself.
So in this process of saying
I wanna impact people,
make people's lives better.
I wanna try to figure out if
it's what I actually wanna do
and not just what I wanna do in a sense
where other people would
like me because of it,
if that makes sense.
- Very self aware.
- I want a selfishly think that
you've been paying attention
to a lot of my content,
because that is one great wrap up
of the enormous amount of content
that I've been putting out
for the last nine months.
- [Felix] I've watched you
for the past two and a half years, Gary.
I literally wake up and
sleep to your voice.
- Listen bro, you don't
know what I just felt like.
It's back to giving.
To hear a young man
articulate that statement,
I'm quite aware of how much pressure.
You know, a lot of people wanna think
that the only thing I'm
putting out there is hustle.
I am putting out a ton of content
that speaks to happiness
and actually mental health
through self awareness,
and more importantly, this whole
Keeping Up With the Joneses
or a.k.a. wanting to be liked
and finding the balance of that,
bro you nailed it, let me
tell you one thing though.
Tom, on episode 299 to
make this full circle,
looked me dead in the face and said,
"Your super power is you
don't judge yourself,"
and he's not wrong.
- Your super power is
you don't judge yourself.
- You're right.
- That became very clear to me.
And I think that's amazing.
- You nailed that.
And you know what else
not judging yourself does,
you don't judge other people either.
And I think what I'm trying to tell you
is back to the way that Scott
has done such a great job in the lexicon,
this is again very meta,
of saying, don't say give back, say give.
I'm gonna tell you something.
If you're doing something
nice for somebody else,
if you're giving,
I am telling you right now,
as somebody who's in your
ear morning and night
for the last two and a half years,
please hear this and repeat it,
and we'll send the clip to you.
If you're doing something nice,
don't judge yourself if you're doing that
for selfish reasons.
It's a hell of a lot better
to try to become liked
because you're helping another human,
than because you bought Gucci loafers.
At some level we have to
stop judging ourselves,
and in the actual action
of doing the right thing,
you know I like to always
say doing the right thing
is the right thing.
That's what this is brother.
You're a young dude.
I can tell you right now that
Scott and I are blown away
about things we've
discovered about ourselves
over the last three years as
men that are pretty self aware
and like to think about this shit
and are pretty in tune.
I'm baffled by my ability to continue
to turn new stones every day.
How old are you?
- [Felix] 25.
- Brother, you're gonna
keep learning about yourself
all the time, but please,
please let this little rant
allow you to not judge
yourself of why you wanna give.
If you wanna posture into society
that you're a good person
or you're part of a cause,
but you actually execute,
then you're doing the right thing.
To me where it gets
dangerous is the following,
and you've heard me say this.
If your a keyboard warrior,
and you put out an Instagram post of like
big ups to the people fighting
the fires in California,
but you don't have the
ability to write a $25 check
or to send some water to
somebody or make a phone call.
If you don't do something tangible
to the keyboard warriorness.
If you just tweet #metoo,
but you do nothing about it.
Or in real life you're
actually a douchebag
to the female race.
If you're a hypocrite,
then you're posturing.
But if you're actually doing something,
if you go this Thanksgiving,
and take mashed potatoes and
put them in somebody's plate
or if you got with 13 bucks and buy a toy
at the dollar store and
drop it off in the lobby,
like all these little things that I act on
that I think about that are subtle.
There is no content around it,
but it's in my constant motion of doing,
not speaking to doing.
If you're actually giving brother,
who gives a fuck if
people think you're good
because of it?
You're actually doing.
Stop judging yourself.
- [Felix] I really appreciate that.
- Does that make sense?
- [Felix] No, that makes perfect sense.
- I'm gonna go very narrow here,
because it's more for my audience.
Knowing that you've
figured out what the fuck
I've been saying about
Keeping Up With the Joneses,
there's a big difference
bro between the Mercedes
and the watch and getting
people to like you
and that's the insecurity,
versus you going and doing
something that gives value
to another human being.
One, you're making an impact.
The other you're creating a vulnerability.
- [Felix] Got it.
- And I love how you
thoughtfully put them together
because you're right.
It's my biggest ah ha.
You know what brother, I'm gonna honor you
by being so thoughtful with your question.
Let me tell you the worst
thing that ever happened to me
when Scott changed the course of my life
by inspiring me to be actively good
in a different way than I
thought about it in the past.
I was always a good guy.
I would always help.
The amount of people that
owe me money is absurd.
I think I could buy the Jets with I.O.U.s.
I always did a lot of good things,
but never thought about it as macro.
I was very immigrant family.
Like you know you did it for your cousin
or an employee.
It was very insular.
The biggest fuck of my life
and I say this sometimes,
but it's fun to say with Scott here is
when I figured out that
there's certain people
in the well group,
there's certain people at
Pencils of Promises's board.
There's certain people at
all the other good things
that I've done in my life
and why they're really there
is to paint the picture
of themselves to other powerful people
so they can use that
leverage to make money
in the outside world broke my heart.
Intent matters.
- Yeah, I think so.
- But, let me just finish,
and then I'll let you jump in.
But back to the advice I gave you,
still the action of doing good,
because there's a lot
of other ways to posture
in front of important people
that don't need you to spend four hours
at an off site for a board
and thing of that nature.
The action of good is always good,
and I would eliminate
that judgment my guy.
- Just what you were saying.
Again if the vision is
to reinvent charity,
charity means love.
Charity means to help
your neighbor in need,
getting nothing in return.
Not status in return, not
financial wins for your business,
it's a pure act, caritas in Latin.
- Scott, that's why I don't
talk about my charity work.
- [Scott] I know, I know.
- And people have a tough
time with me on that.
- But at our galas, one
of the things early on
we did what everybody else did.
10 years ago, we would
sell the Prada handbag
for five grand.
We would sell the week in Telluride,
the $25,000 Hublot watch.
And I realize we were
doing the wrong thing.
This wasn't pure charity.
It also wasn't working
because we had people in
the buy side of their brain.
You would look at that $25,000 watch,
and be like I'd never pay 25 for that.
I know a guy at Hublot,
I'd pay five or 10,
or I would never pay that
for a weekend in Telluride.
So everybody's dealing.
So 10 years ago we just said,
we're gonna give people nothing.
They're gonna come into our gala.
We're gonna give them an opportunity
to be the most generous
version of themselves.
I actually say that from stage now.
I'm so intentional about this language.
You are coming and you're
gonna leave with nothing.
You're gonna leave with
nothing except the fact
that you know you used your resources
to end needless suffering,
and to the degree that
you use those resources.
And you're gonna go home and
your wife or your husband
or your partner is gonna look at you
hopefully with respect and admiration
because you did it for the right reasons.
The minute we did that,
I remember the first year
we did away with the crap,
we doubled the race.
We literally doubled it.
Last year we raised $4.6 million.
We fed people a chicken dinner.
Like a rubber chicken dinner.
Almost 400 people.
There were people that just
responded to the stories.
We were trying to call forth
the greatest goodness in them,
and then believe that
they would be transformed
through that unselfish act of giving.
And that that would create
the desire to do more.
They would almost get
addicted to that unselfishness
and say wow, it actually feels better.
Think about it, if you're
giving because you care,
and not giving with an ulterior motive,
you sleep better at night.
You just do.
You gave because you wanted to respond.
You looked at a problem and said
I have the resources to solve that,
a little bit of that,
so I think I would encourage you
to make sure you're giving,
follow this pursuit.
Go learn video.
Go learn photographs.
Go learn how to tell stories,
that it sounds like tell
stories that honor people
and boast, maybe elevate their condition.
And you'll find yourself hopefully
just really engaged in
the redemptive pure aspect
of that work that you'll
just wanna do more of it.
- And oh by the way,
for everybody who's watching,
and be selfish to what
makes you happy too.
I always say to people,
the reason I feel like I can give so much
is because my selflessness
comes from my selfishness.
I think one of the things
that people have to understand
is there's easy ways to
compartment all this stuff.
It's okay to buy yourself
a fancy Hawaiian vacation
if that's what you and your partner want.
I feel like people are play
within your own framework.
There is no right way.
Guess what?
- I'm no martyr.
Doing this is an amazing thing.
I love my job.
I get to travel around.
- And by the way, just to
wrap some of these things
for the themes of today,
by the way, go spend 18 years
building a great business if
that's what makes you happy.
And then sell it,
and by the way, don't give away 99%.
Give away five percent.
Give away one percent.
By the way, look I think that
what's so important right now
to me more than ever,
is eliminating judgment.
People give in many different ways.
Listen, there's
organizations and individuals
that I give more of time to.
There's places where I
give more of my money to.
I'm not gonna feel crippled by anybody.
They don't know.
First of all, nobody knows.
I don't know 99% about Scott.
What happens in his bedroom, in his head,
on a flight when he's by himself.
I mean this is just a loaded question.
How different of a man are you today
than you were when you were 25 years old?
- I was scum bag at 25.
I was degenerate.
25, I was addicted to cocaine,
gambling, alcohol, strip
clubs, and pornography,
and about two to three packs
of Marlboro Reds a day.
- For everybody who's watching right now
and worried about being too ideological
or holy shit feeling pressure
like I'm a bad person,
like why'd I buy a
Nintendo Wii last night?
I should've given it to the kids.
Life is long.
Eliminate the judgment
about yourself first.
- And your past does
not dictate your future.
That was really the point
of writing the book,
was the book starts with me doing drugs
and falling through a
plate glass window at NYU.
Like off my face.
To then go to the emergency room.
Get all fixed up and
then go work at Twilo,
some club back in the day.
If you had ever seen the wreck
of a human being that I was,
this is never someone that's
gonna start a charity.
This is never someone that's gonna
have a healthy marriage and kids.
This is never someone that's
gonna leave any purpose,
or lead a life with purpose.
My tombstone was actually,
had you met me at 25, my
tombstone was going to read,
here lies a guy who died prematurely young
of a drug overdose and
managed to get millions
of people wasted before he died
as a night club promoter.
And now at 43 my tombstone is
gonna be a little different.
- A hell of a lot better.
And guess what, let me go the reverse.
Something I think about everyday,
and guess what, you could crush it,
and you're the most noble
motherfucker of all time
to 47, and then you're not.
- You could finish badly, exactly.
I think about finishing well all the time.
- As you should especially
if you've ever had not good.
If you've had not good and
now you're in the good zone.
- And we have kids too.
We start thinking about the men
we wanna be for our
children and our wives.
- I've had some really
deep conversations lately
of people that feel in a trap of nobleness
because of their parents,
but don't feel accountable to their kids.
I had the craziest convo I've ever had.
I'm sorry, I just I couldn't believe this.
Somebody telling me
that they couldn't wait
for their parents to die so
they could have some fun.
And just everybody's
living different lives.
- [Felix] Do you guys
have an practical advice
on getting rid of that poison?
- Well look, I think you're
doing it right now brother.
I think one of the quickest
ways to get out poison
is to over communicate
and expose yourself.
That's what Scott did.
How many people are pumped about talking
about being addicted to
pornography, cocaine?
I think you're doing it.
- I just do it to help people.
- And it helped you too bro.
- [Scott] There's a trust too.
- Bro, listen what happened with me.
You wanna know I became the entrepreneur?
- I'm just doing therapy in front
of 10,000 people on stages.
- You know why I became the
entrepreneur's entrepreneur?
Let me give you the preview.
In 2006, seven, eight, nine, 10,
when it wasn't as cool to
go to Mount Ida College
and get Ds and Fs, and all that.
When everybody judged
me because they all went
to Georgetown and Yale and all this.
In my circle, of all the
Silicon Valley winners,
I kept doing it.
Because it was my truth,
it was liberating.
It was the truth.
And then the market moved in a way
that made it more acceptable.
What would I do if I were you?
I'd go on Instagram right
now and make a video
and tell every fucking
secret, insecurity you got,
just completely let it go.
It might feel safe in this
environment right here.
Put it in every circle of your life.
It will lose its leverage.
- [Felix] Right.
- Our secrets of our insecurities
are the jails of our emotions.
The way to free it up is
to put it out in the wild.
I have very deep friends
and family right now
that I wish they'd make
one 60 second video
on Instagram and tell the world the truth
of the one thing they've been holding.
They wouldn't believe how light
they would feel the next day.
I believe that.
- And that was this
process for me as well.
- Thanks brother, thanks for calling.
Final thoughts brother.
Hey first of all if you're watching.
Please it would mean a lot to
me if you supported this book.
A, you should read the story,
B, it's the kind of book that lays around
on your coffee table, in your dorm room,
in your vacation home, at your office,
that somebody else picks up,
and it becomes one of those
serendipitous stories.
For some reason you Air
BnBed out your house.
You left it on the thing.
- We're hearing those
stories already, honestly.
- So that would mean a lot to me.
I think one of the reasons
I like to give, give, give,
and then occasionally ask
is it gives you the leverage
to come through,
and look this is a very
important week for me.
I've been working
secretly on a wine project
for a long time,
and I'm gonna ask a whole lot,
but if you ask you the truth in my soul,
I'd rather you buy this
book than the project
and so that would mean a lot to me.
Any final thoughts?
- I'm just grateful.
Grateful for you
and it's been a long journey.
- It has.
And we haven't even fucking started.
Like I mean it.
- I actually feel like
we're at the beginning.
- I genuinely do.
- It feels like the beginning.
I say that now.
- I feel it.
- It's the beginning of the journey.
The best is yet to come.
- I had a premonition right now
that the new OTT, which is the new cable,
which is the new network,
you and are sitting and doing
something as 68 year olds.
First weirdly, we both look great.
Second, I think-
- Considering my history, it's amazing.
- Look, at 25 years old,
and this is.
- I'm not twitching.
How old are you right now?
- 43.
- When did you turn 43?
- September seventh.
- God, that's right, you're
two months older than me.
I turn 43 in two days.
For me, when you were 25,
you were doing what you said.
At 25, I spent every
hour in a liquor store
in Springfield, New Jersey,
and 18 years later, here both we are,
making impacts in our different ways
that matter to the Zeitgeist today.
And guess what?
In 18 years we're only 61.
Young as fuck.
(Scott laughs)
I believe that.
61.
Almost every 61 year old
I know is doing things
that matter right now, like young.
And with modern medicine
and the way we're taking
care of ourselves.
It's gonna be an amazing journey
and I'm so appreciative that
we crossed paths brother.
I'm so proud of you, you don't even know.
- Thanks man.
- Thanks for being on the show.
- Love you.
- Love you more.
You keep asking questions.
We'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)